Come on, you.
Get the show on the road.
You got a bunch of stuff
to talk about.
And you don't love me,
right?
If you really love me,
You'll give you the one thing
that I really crave,
which is a divorce.
I was super
excited to work with you
because I've been such
a fan of yours.
And then you came in.
You just blew
everybody away.
Take off your glasses.
Are you trying
to divorce me on acid?
You're not thinking
straight.
That's
why I'm thinking straight.
This isn't old Peggy
Newman.
I’m a P.I.
and I'm working up
a case.
Is that a lady’s finger?
Ta-da!
It’s nice to do something where
there's so much history
right at the onset.
This just sounds like
another
one of those crazy things
you're
trying between rehabs.
Come on. I'm like Mary
Tyler Moore on methadone.
Peggy,
to me, is a real hustler.
But you are the only person
who out hustles her.
There she is.
Are you fucking kidding me?
But Danny is a schemer.
But he really believes
in this new spiritual path.
I've got an email
list of men
who are looking for
a safe place
to practice Qigong and shit.
We meet him early
in this story,
and he wants his woman back.
He wants his wife back.
Look at you.
I know.
You're fuckin Phoenix, baby.
He hasn't decided
that they're divorced yet.
Trust me, I'm the man.
I'm going to take care of
things.
It'll be good for us
in the end.
You're such a fucking liar.
I only lied so we could be
together when I got out.
Can I have a coffee
and an apple pie
and a prime rib to go and
give this fucker the check?
They both have these wedding
bands
tattooed to their fingers,
but hers has been covered
with an ax.
You know, Peg,
I choose to focus
on the good times,
not the bad.
You ruined the holiday Teddy.
It's very authentic to me.
And that's the thing
that I like
more than anything
about this.
The best
parts of them are aligned
and the worst parts of them
are aligned.
Maybe I’ve been
a little hard on you.
I still want to give you
the benefit of the doubt.
You know.
I am trying.
Thank you for seeing that.
Can I call you back?
Where would you see
Peggy and Denny
10 years from now,
if they're both alive